effectivement thème cette affaire du
pont Moretti elle marque la rentrée du
Parlement et de l'exécutif bonjour
Franck Riester bonjour La dessinateurs
ont été un petit peu déçus finalement
par la réponse de la première ministre
qui dit
Eric Dupond-Moretti est un justiciable
comme les autres les sénateurs ont
rappelé qu'Emmanuel Macron avait fixé
cette règle avait dit qu'il la respecte
en tout cas une vieille règle un
ministre mise en examen doit
démissionner ça veut dire quoi son
maintien en poste ça veut dire que c'est
la fin de la moralisation de la vie
publique qui avait été promise par
Emmanuel Macron non pas du tout nous
sommes toujours très attachés cette
moralisation de la vie publique mais
c'est simplement respecter nos
institutions espacées nos règles de
droit nous sommes dans un état de droit
et la mise en examen ne signifie pas
culpabilité ou condamnation il y a la
présomption d'innocence et vous savez
cette présentation d'innocence c'est une
protection pour tous nos compatriotes
qui peuvent à un moment ou un autre de
leur vie être face à la justice et la
mise en examen n'est pas une
condamnation et il y a la présomption
d'innocence qui s'applique aussi aux
responsables politiques à commencer par
les ministres et donc bien évidemment si
on ajoute en plus la question de la
entre la justice l'exécutif et le
législatif les choses sont claires
carrées et le ministre de la Justice à
toute la confiance du président et la
première ministre est-ce qu'il va
pouvoir continuer à exercer son action
sereinement alors qu'il pourrait être
amené à donner son avis sur la
nomination de son propre accusateur en
l'occurrence le procureur général de la
Cour de cassation qui va être remplacé
en 2023 il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont évidemment pris en
compte directement par la Premier
ministre dans le cadre du principe dit
de déport les choses sont très claires
très cadrées et il y a aucun risque en
la matière un mot sur cette rentrée
parlementaire tendue entre par le mont
et gouvernement on parle d'utilisation
du 49-3 de motion de censure de
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que vous dites en tant que
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
ça va pas tenir un quinquennat
finalement le gouvernement va être
censuré avant la fin du quinquennat bon
d'abord j'ai apprécié la sérénité des
débats au Sénat par rapport à ce qu'on a
pu constater hier à l'Assemblée
nationale mais au-delà de cette remarque
nous nous sommes toujours fidèles à
l'engagement du prime de la République
le prénom de la République qui a été
réélu il y a quelques mois qui a une
majorité certes relative pas de majorité
absolue mais enfin une majorité relative
quand même pour répondre aux
problématiques de notre compatriotes
pour les protéger face par exemple au
prix de l'énergie préparer l'avenir en
matière de travail d'emploi de recherche
d'innovation de sécurité et donc nous
allons continuer d'agir en travaillant
d'une façon constructive avec les
parlementaires en mettant de côté le
plus possible tout le bruit médiatique
ou le bruit politique de certains qui
veulent le désordre à la fois à
l'Assemblée nationale et dans la rue qui
veulent créer les tensions voir les
révolutions dans le pays plutôt que de
répondre d'une façon constructive au
problématique de nos compatriotes et on
a vu au mois de juillet et début août
que ça fonctionnait on a voté un projet
de loi de finance rectificatif un projet
de loi pouvoir d'achat qui a permis de
voter 20 milliards d'euros de soutien à
nos compatriotes qui voient d'ores et
déjà les conséquences positives pour eux
dans leur vie au quotidien et nous
allons continuer sur tous les textes qui
arrivent à l'ordre du jour du Parlement
au Sénat et à nationale sur le travail
sur les énergies renouvelables sur la
sécurité et si nous devons un moment ou
un autre par exemple sur les lois de
finances ou les lois de finance de la
sécurité sociale prendre nos
responsabilités en utilisant des outils
que nous donne la Constitution pour
s'assurer que la France a un budget et
un budget de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous le ferons en sérénité comme
d'autres gouvernements avant nous l'ont
utilisé et si au terme de la
concertation qui est lancé sur la
réforme des retraites plusieurs mois et
bien si au terme de cette concertation
vous n'obtenez pas de majorité vous
prendrez aussi vos responsabilités vous
utiliserez l'article 49-3 qui vous est
permis c'est-à-dire de passer en force à
l'Assemblée sur sur un texte par session
alors sur cette question de la réforme
des retraites contrairement à ce que
certains ont pu évoquer il y a pas de
passage en force il y a pas d'amendement
nous passons par un texte spécifique qui
sera
précisé présenté en début d'année voté
avant l'hiver et d'ici là c'est la
concertation Olivier du socle le
ministre du Travail reçoit aujourd'hui
les organisations syndical la première
ministre va réunir les présidents groupe
à recevoir les présidents de groupe avec
Olivier du shop et moi-même et ensuite
des concertations vont avoir lieu
jusqu'à mi-décembre et me disant on fera
le point et on dira quels sont les
grandes lignes du projet loi qui sera
présentée ensuite en conseil des
ministres au début de l'année prochaine
et vous voyez nous voulons en toute
clarté personne n'est pris par surprise
qui était dans le projet du premier
République dans le projet des députés
aux élections législatives réformer
notre système de retraite pour le
pérenniser et pour financer les avancées
sociales et les services publics dont
nous avons besoin nous allons faire dans
la concertation dans l'ouverture mais
avec force et décision on peut imaginer
une réforme des retraites passées en
49-3 mais écoutez si jamais nous devions
pas avoir à l'issue de ce travail
constructif à la fois de concertation et
de travail parlementaire de majorité
nous prendrons nos responsabilités comme
nous le prendrons pour tous les textes
parce que c'est ça la conviction qui est
la nôtre ouverture concertation respect
des oppositions mais à un moment donné
il faut décider agir pour nos
compatriotes merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été au micro de Public Sénat
[Musique]